I'd like to now calculate the angular
momentum of a two particle system so
here's one particle called that one and
here's the other particle two and
particle one is has a momentum in the
downward direction and particle two has
a momentum in the upper direction now in
this case I want to make the sum of the
momentum so this momentum of the system
is zero and now I want to calculate the
angular momentum about two different
points so let's just draw an axis here
and let's choose one point a and we'll
call this distance R and this distance R
and let's choose another point B and
we'll call that distance D now in order
to calculate angular momentum of the
system I need to draw my vectors let's
start with the angular momentum about
the point a that's going to be a vector
from a to object one across the momentum
of one plus the vector from a to object
to cross the momentum of - now what's
crucial here is at this point things are
a little bit of an abstract but we want
to draw these vectors are a 1 in our a 2
so we're now constructing our angular
momentum diagrams so there's our a1 and
there's our a tube but again in order to
calculate this we could do it
geometrically with right hand rules but
I now want to introduce unit vectors so
I can do vector decomposition at every
point so I'm gonna choose a unit vector
I hat J hat and k hat and now I can
decompose all of these vectors in terms
of my unit vectors this is the angular
momentum of the system so now it's not
hard at all to write these out our a1 is
minus R in the I hat direction cross P
one is down that's minus P one in the J
hat direction where P one is the
magnitude and RA two is in the plus I
hat direction so that's our I had
and I'm crossing that with p2 which I'll
write right now is p2 in the J hat
direction
now remember p2 has the same magnitude
as p1 but they're pointing in opposite
directions so when I take the cross
product I hat cross J hat is K hat minus
sign minus sign so I get our p1 k hat
and now over here p2 is equal to p1
I had cross J hat is K hat and I get
another are p1 km and so I have two are
p1 k and that's the angular momentum of
the system about point a now I'd like to
calculate the angular momentum about B
so let's draw the same diagram one
- here's p2 here is p1 here's B and now
I'll draw my vectors this is our B - and
this is our B 1 this distance was to are
this distance was D I'm going to use the
same unit vectors and so I get L for the
system about B again I'll just write
everything out P 1 plus RB 2 cross P 2
so I'm going to write P 2 as in this
case it's equal to minus P 1 and
magnitudes p2 equals P 1 in magnitude
directions are opposite so RB 1 is equal
to 2r plus D I I had and it's pointing
in the minus I hat direction cross P 1
is in the minus J hat direction RB 2 is
also in the - I had direction so that's
minus D I had
and p2 is in the plus J direction so
that is plus the magnitudes of the same
p1 J hat we don't need the plus sign
there and now I take the cross products
I hat cross J hat is K hat a minus sign
minus sign that makes plus so I have two
R Plus D P 1 K hat now notice here I
have I hat cross J hat which is K hat
but there's a minus sign so I have minus
D P 1 K hat here I have Plus D P 1 K at
minus D 1 PK ed and so I get to R P 1 K
hat and I have the same result L system
a equals L system B now that's not a
coincidence in this problem and the
reason is that whenever so we can say it
this way whenever the momentum of the
system is 0 then L a is independent of
the choice
of the point eight so coming back to our
example no matter where I picked our
points a and B any point I could pick
anywhere I want I could pick a point C
up there I make this cross-product
calculation I would get exactly the same
answer to our p1k